AAAH! FUCK YEW!
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to The Visitor.
Now this is the first vee-vi-vi- Oculus Vive horror game that I played.
I don't know if it's the best
but it's the first one that I found
and I need to pay attention to flickering lights, so...
Apparently- oh.
Okay, that was already a little spooky.
Oh, hello.
HI!
Oh, god. Oh, hello!
Okay?
So apparently there is no controller-
[weird robot noises]
There's no controller support needed.
[footsteps]
Hi~!
|fart]
Is that you, mother?
Are you come to tuck to me in tonight?
If that was even words in a sentence?
Okay, so...
[weird sound]
Supposedly, I just sit here like the good little boy that I am in my little bed.
Even though it's kind of a sprawled out throne.
It's very delightful.
And I gotta picture of-
Oh, I'm the DAD!
Oh! I'm not a child.
Why did I always default to me being a little boy?
That probably says something about my personality.
And why do I have a grandfather clock in my room?
And why do I sleep with the doors both open?
[more weird noises]
This is seems b- oh.
Okay, THAT is-
That is a very bizarre painting to have above my bed.
Or- not above my bed, but looking above my bed.
Uh-oh.
Oookay! And that's another odd painting to have in my room staring at me.
[scared] OOOH HI!
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
ARE YOU FRIENDLY?
PROBABLY NOT!
(Just doing Laundry)
OH, HI!
HONEY! IS THAT YOU?
Darling, dear?
Awww, my lovely wife!
Come to tuck me in!
I like to roleplay that I'm a-
Chuh-
I'm one of those adults that- adult baby diap-
Uuugh, come on, NOhoho!
Heeey! I'm good this time!
I'm good!
I was about to say ad- adult baby diaper fetishists.
Not that I'm-
Hyo
Opposed to anybody liking what th-
Ah, screw it! Whatever.
I'm in a horror game right now.
Why am I talking about that?
Mkay.
Ooooh!
Oh, good! I needed a little more draft.
Here.
Is that another door?
Ohh, this is just delightful.
Oh, what am I doing here?
[louder and louder noise]
Hi~?
[crescendo continues]
[noise stops]
Okay!
That was cool. Nothing happened.
But you know, I'm still here
and alive
and talking...
[floor squeaks]
Aw, shit.
OKAY!
What's up?
AAAH, SHET!
Now, that was flickering outside of my room, now it's flickering inside of my room.
AEHH, COME ON NOW!
Oh, you gotta go with the horror movie cliché?
Well, how about a little bit of this?
I mean, you can't see it in the game, but I'm doing it hard!
That's what I thought.
There- BLAAAH FUCK YEW!
YOU WANNA MESS WITH ME?
HUUUH?
Don't mind my prepubescent, cracking voice!
I'm very BRAVE and MANLY!
[scary sound]
AAH! FUCK YOU!
See? See, the way I shouted that was in a brave and manly way!
It scared THEM
so MUCH
that they ran away.
And that's the point that I'm trying to make here.
[clock chimes]
Okay, that's good.
Midnight.
The perfect time for me to beat the shit out of the ghost in my house.
And also bury all the repressed memories of my probably dead child
AND dead wife.
Great!
[woman whispering]: Knight to F4.
Knight to F4?
Oh, okay! Chess, I gue-uugh.
Fuck you!
NO!
THAT'S GONNA CHECKMATE ME!
OH, GOD!
Okay.
Alright, then.
Well, that was a whole lotta nothin'!
Mr. Braveman- Oh god, it's getting closer!
[woman's whisper]: Don't play with him.
What did you say to me?
[woman's whisper]: I don't want you to play with him.
Wh- I wasn't gonna!
I didn't plan on it!
AAAH, WHAT THE FUCK?!
OKAY! FUCK YOU!
WHAT THE FUCK?!
Oookay, hi!
Alright!
You still there?
Are you still there?
Ooookay!
Don't like that!
Whaathefeeerck
Okay.
Was it just me or did she see-
[TV squeals]
Eugh.
Was it just me or did she seem really big?
[TV squeals]
Hi~! [squealing stops]
Test of our emergency broadcast system?
I think I should probably get out of bed now!
[woman whispering]: I don't like the way she looks at me.
Oh!
Whe- uh- okay!
Wh- I didn't like that anyway!
It was creeping me out, too, I'm glad we're on the same p- excuse my spit!
[woman speaking]: Hi, Teddy.
"Hi, Teddy"?
Oh, hey!
Awww- Uh-oh.
Wha- he's murdered.
Well, better you than me, buddy!
I'd rather be here and not dead
than over there and probably DEFINITELY dead.
okeh
((surprise mothafucka))
AAAH! FUCK YEW!
WHAT THE FUCK?!
Okay, FUCK OFF!
Hi.
You're d-
Oh, okay.
IS THAT IT?!
IS THAT THE END OF IT?!
REALLY?
[cracking sounds]
Oh god, that didn't sound good.
[woman laughing]
Huh. Is someone playing with my brain?
Oh!
Oh, good!
Oh, okay.
Hi!
Love the change!
That's WAY better.
Ahh, shhheit.
I gotta be careful- Oh, god damnit. That too?!
What happened to Teddy?
YOU OKAY?
[Dead Teddy silence]
He doesn't look so good.
So- Oh, and the closet's open?
Oh god, no ;-;
hhh
I don't like- AHH, FUCK YOU!
I see- OOH NO-HO!
HI THERE BIG NO-NO ON THAT ONE!
HOW ABOUT A BIG NEGATORY ON THAT!
Uhhh, don't you come over MY bed!
Hoooo, I'mma catch you!
Come into m- AAAAAAAAH! FOCK!
Okay.
Ohh, good.
Allll done then.
Grreat!
Well...
[giggles]
[sniffs]
Man, it's so weird taking off my headset and being in my room just standing around.
But that was cool, I gotta admit. That was really cool.
So, hope you guys enjoyed that! If you know of other horror games that I can play for the Oculus Veev-
whatever
VIVE
There we go, VIVE...
Then let me know in the comments below and let me know what you thought of this one.
Thanks again everybody for watching, and as always I will see you...
In the next video!
Buh-bye!
[outro music] *Markimoo creates the new dance trend*